Alors ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas fait une petite FAQ
Une petite réponse aux questions
On se détend, let's go !
C'est quand ta prochaine FAQ ?
Euuh.. bah maintenant
Pourquoi n'envisages-tu pas la chirurgie maintenant que tu es riche ?
*Musique Triste*
Tu sais quoi Hugo ?
T'as raison, je vais me faire refaire le visage
Tu as couché avec combien de femmes ?
2000 !
Quelle est ta position préférée ?
C'est un peu osé comme réponse mais moi j'aime bien être assis
Voilà, là je suis assis j'aime bien ...
Tu voudrais avoir un autre animal domestique ?
Alors en ce moment je réfléchis éventuellement à posséder un aigle
Hein c'est un projet je voulais peut-être le mettre ici là
Quand est-ce que tu as des muscles ?
Alors j'aurais des muscles le 5 janvier
C'est prévu c'est planifié sur mon planning c'est écrit le 5 janvier "j'ai des muscles"
Seras-tu à la "Video City Paris" ?
OUI !!
Tu te filmes avec quelle caméra ?
C'est vraiment la voix du mec, il parle comme ça dans la vie
Alors voici un petit miroir pour que vous puissiez voir la caméra
avec laquelle je me filme
A l'école, tu étais plutôt le leader ou la victime ?
A l'époque je me posais pas cette question tu vois ?
Moi j'avais une philosophie de, on est tous les mêmes, on est tous égaux
On s'entraîde mutuellement et ... Après je me fais raquetter hein ça c'est après
Fais un "tuto beauté" !
Bah si tu veux on peut faire un "tuto orthographe" ça serait peut-être plus utile pour toi
Peux-tu dire quelque chose en Ch'ti ?
Alors attention, tous les gens qui me trouvait classe jusqu'à présent
C'est à dire personne
Bah vous allez être déçu
(mots en Ch'ti)
Ça veut dire: "Enlève ton chapeau, enlève tes chaussettes...
et ferme ta gueule"
voilà c'est un truc que tu dis rarement dans la vie
Quand tes fans te reconnaissent dans la rue, qu'est-ce qu'il te disent tout le temps en premier ?
Ah ! Bah c'est vrai que souvent les gens quand ils me reconnaissent dans la rue ils me disent :
Putai* c'est vrai que dans tes vidéos tu fais un peu fragile et tout, mais en vrai t'es beaucoup plus "homme"
Tu sais plus viril tout ça...
Et c'est faux !
C'est complètement faux ! Ils disent jamais ça
Combien de personnes te reconnaissent par jour en moyenne ?
...
Zéro !
Quand je reste chez moi...
Tu as déménagé ou c'est le décor qui a changé ?
Et bah oui ! J'ai déménagé plusieurs fois et je suis maintenant ici
dans cet appartement qui n'est pas un décor, hein, c'est mon vrai appart'
Comme le prouve par exemple... ces haricots verts
Ou cet énorme "cat" !
Salut, j'adore ce que tu fais
Comment est la relation avec ton père et toi?
J'ai l'impression que ce mec veut être mon psy..
Moi et mon père on a toujours été proches
Lorsqu'il rentrait le soir et qu'il me fouettait avec sa ceinture
c'etait des moments de souffrance
et en même temps de joie
Tu me crois quand je te dis que je suis Batman?
euh non ..
"un conseil pour être musclé ?"
Alors, si je peux donner un conseil pour être musclé
C'est de ne pas suivre mes conseils
Comme tu peux le voir sur mon corps
Ça a été un échec
Il était comment ce poulet de deux semaines ?
Qu'as tu ramené du Québec ?
Petit souvenirs, j'ai ramené cette petite sucette en forme de sirop d'érable
ça ne veut rien dire d'ailleurs, en forme de feuille d'érable
Elisandre ! Qui est entrain de se marrer tabernacle
Salut Youtube comment ça va ?  Le gangnam style !
-Arrêtes de parle, arretes de parler c'est horrible
Tu sais qu'on en a besoin, hein ?
Vas tu faire une vidéo avec Lisandre?
Alors ça non, hors de question ! Out of the question !
Tu as aimé cette expérience au Québec?
J'ai adoré le Québec, j'ai adoré les québecois par contre appelé un happy meal
j'ai adoré le Quebec , j'ai adoré les quebecois